[Applause]
hello pork nation welcome to another
episode of the poured reports my name is
Ashe Crossan and with me is my co
reigning pork Queen Emma Feist I am very
excited to be here when you reached out
to me and said do you want to do a video
about pork the answer was well obviously
these do you even have to ask it's so
funny because you and I have never never
never actually met is happening right
it's true right here on camera
surrounded by pork the way it was meant
to be meant to be because we know each
other because of pork is that actually
is a hundred percent true because the
thing is it's like I both of us through
various internet channels became sort of
infamous for our love of these weird
little space puffins yes and other
people kind of started tagging us in the
same tweets and that's sort of how this
this friendship this mutual Porsche love
and friendship has begun yes um you have
more more clout more pork cloud because
when you search for poor gifts yeah
you're all over them it's true if you if
you go to giffy if you have that on your
phone or you just go to giffy on the
internet and you search pork my face is
all over this this little guys all over
it as well yes we have a wonderful team
of givers that make gifts essentially
for the twitch channel that I work for
and and here we are so we're gonna out
we've got we are all porn we are we are
I I do I have a little pork in my pocket
here if you guys can see the funny thing
is about this shirt is I believe it's a
gift from my sister-in-law for Christmas
it arrived at my house in a package that
was addressed to me but had no other
indication so maybe it's from her maybe
it's from someone on the internet I
don't know but it's got a port on it so
here we are
well before we we get all into the
Portuguese people I'm sure are asking
you endlessly how you feel about a
certain scene yes and sure I think I
have not responded yet I haven't really
either because I've been wanting to do a
video where I just exclusively talk and
really like vet my feelings
so this is gonna be a little bit of a
therapy but before we get into that
let's just talk about the last Jedi
overall but yes I don't know if you've
had enough time to process your feelings
I you know it's been a journey it has
been a journey it's really interesting
because my reaction upon leaving the
theatre was I think I loved it right
there so so much to process in this
movie because I mean Rian Johnson is
such an interesting filmmaker from the
point of view and I've said this in
other outlets as well that he doesn't
tell the audience what to think
he just presents you with the story and
allows you to formulate your own opinion
so whereas JJ Abrams is a very very good
job at telling a movie that is about
Star Wars and reintroducing Star Wars to
a new generation perhaps or bringing
people back in who haven't been
consuming Star Wars for whatever reason
for a number of years since the prequels
came out though I don't know why you
wouldn't there's so much other Star Wars
media to consume but what the difference
is is I feel that force awakens is it's
a film it's Star Wars it's what we
expect and Rian Johnson has made a film
that is a film that is about something
and also happens to be Star Wars right
so it's not to say that there's anything
wrong with like force awakens or the
more sort of simplistic kind of way that
we've seen Star Wars portrayed over the
years but I actually feel that Rian
Johnson's film last Jedi is kind of
reminiscent of the direction that Star
Wars has been going in some of the other
media where you start seeing these
characters that are a lot more shades of
grey I mean even in Star Wars rebels
which is a show that is a it's a cartoon
it's for kids right but it doesn't treat
kids like they're dumb and and I think
that that is something that we see
really reflected in this as well where
it's like not everything is so black and
white and good and evil like there are
shades of grey and I said it before in
the trailer they warn you they pick a
very specific line to feature in the
trailer for the last Jedi which is Luke
saying this is not going to go the way
you think right because it's so
unpredictable and that that line is
essentially my review
yeah it's just like this isn't gonna go
the way you think anything Oh what
happened it's really not and I really
appreciate because I felt that it wasn't
ryan johnson basically going Oh screw
you guys I know you've got all these
theories I'm just gonna blow him up like
everything was justified agree in the
way that he did it I do I think that it
was amazing that he just blew
everybody's theories about you know like
a certain evil overlord out of the water
so we'll never know yeah I should
probably warn spoilers yeah no I totally
agree with you and I I've I did a video
with with Jermaine Lewis here where we
had just we were talking about the last
shot it for the first time it was the
first time that we had ever outloud
talked about the Millers and so I'm
watching this video back and I'm like
I'm clearly just still processing
everything I don't really know how to
Fischer we're kind of like telling both
sides or like I like this but here's
what I didn't like about it but here's
why it's actually actually works and now
that I've had this time to process it
it's like I love it so much it's a movie
that you keep thinking about and the
more I think about it and the more I
talk about it with other people
the more I love it right which isn't to
say that it's a perfect film by any
means I do think that you know there's
there's a little bit of a pacing issue
towards the middle with all the stuff
when they go to canto bite but even that
I understand why that's in the movie I
think there was a way that they could
have done that without the CGI rabbit
horses oh the [ __ ] the fathers yes not
and that wasn't bad it just I feel like
there was a way that we could have
focused more on them connecting with the
orphaned children that were forced to
like take care of these things
boilers but but that being said I didn't
dislike that it was just probably the
weakest part of the film for me but I
did love that so much of Poe and Rose
and Finn story was about failure I
agreement you know that's my biggest
thing about the canto bite thing because
I walked out of the theater being like
that part was a little like of a mission
to serve a purpose
and then you start thinking about it and
it's like and I keep saying this but
like in all of Star Wars it's either the
perfect plan mmm
swimmingly totally or it's a trap yep
and it's like I just loved that it was
these people that were being like
insubordinate and came up with the
stupid work and it but it it served
their character but I was gonna say it's
serve their characters so well and even
though yes they were all definitely
being insubordinate and acting against
orders and it was showing I loved
everything with Poe Dameron in this
storyline I thought that his character
arc was just so fantastic because
because basically they took this
character who existed in force awakens
and he was just like this cool pilot
with a nice jacket yeah bad in the
galaxy yeah who had like some real nice
eye contact with Finn but suddenly we
understand who he is in this movie in
his journey from this hot-headed pilot I
know best I can do everything let's just
blow stuff up to the end where he's like
now we gotta we gotta get out of here we
have to have the resistance survive I'm
gonna find a way out it was so
beautifully crafted agreed and and I
we've seen so much like you know the The
Apprentice Padawan yeah really cool to
see an apprentice relationship with yeah
in the resistance that's so so true but
Anna and I loved everything in this
movie too I felt that just everyone was
introduced in the last movie they just
got so much we got so much more out of
them
right in this film I the the storyline
of Rey you know going to find Luke and
you think it's gonna be this whole thing
where he's like training her to be a
Jedi and then that's not what's
happening at all is so refreshing
honestly and the fact that you know when
when he's first hanging out with Ray and
she's you know got her hands on the
ground and moving the little pebbles and
she immediately just like embraces the
dirt it was so great because I think in
Rey we finally have this character who
every other Jedi character we've seen so
far in in sort of the film Star Wars
Canon has been so afraid of the dark
side it's like oh man I can't go there
it's really bad if I do I'm just gonna
go like full Darth Vader and murder
everyone I just I got it I got a steer
clear like even Anakin Skywalker is he's
going and he's like
I don't want to embrace the dark side we
have Ray who has no real concept
whatsoever and is like not it's got a
thing I need I'm totally gonna use it if
I have to and then you also have on the
far far end of the spectrum kylo Ren who
was such a great character in this film
who's like nah I I'm all dark side I'm
all in the only reason that I want you
to come here so you can join me ray and
we just like rule everything together
it's king and queen yeah oh my god yeah
and I it's it was kind of explored in
the prequels but I don't think it was
stated as well as what it is because it
was like you you live longer and you
have like the well and on and on top of
that like Luke actually breaks it down
really well in this movie where he says
to Rey when she goes there he says it
offered you something you need it right
what I just got a chill saying so yeah I
just think that they they handled what
had become sort of abstract lofty like
very black-and-white concepts in a way
that made it feel very grounded we were
going into this being like are they
gonna like I hate the term great the
great Jedi thing are they just gonna
live and die yeah I don't know for that
sure I like that they kind of they did
it in a way where it wasn't it wasn't
specifically like gray Jedi them it
wasn't this like oh there's a happy
medium a no-no you can explore both
sides but while still being one or the
other anyway I mean I think that that's
also encapsulated really well in that
final conversation that astral
projection
Luke has with kylo Ren where he says to
her I will not be the last Jedi Oh
because but he's also come to terms with
the fact that the Jedi don't as you were
saying they don't have to be so absolute
right that it is possible only assist is
an absolutely yes that it is possible to
carry on the legacy of the Jedi without
having to constantly fear the dark side
and as you say just like deal in while
you're all good or you're all evil right
and that in that also is very much a
capsulated in the fact that Rey's
parents are not part of some great
destined storyline blah blah blah she
just a person and she is strong with the
force because she has to be as Luke
explains because kylo had gotten so
strong here's this little force
sensitive girl Rey
so her powers grew exponentially to
match his to try to restore balance to
the force and it doesn't matter that
she's not somebody is somebody because
she's going to carry on this legacy in
this hope that the idea of the Jedi
bring to the oppressed people right I
don't like my only kind of critique was
they kept teasing the parents thing I
know I know your parents oh I like the
way they handled it too when she went
into like the dark place yes and and it
was just all these reflections of her
and then when she approaches the Oh show
me who my parents are showing her my
parents aren't she looks and it's just
her yeah basically being like it doesn't
matter who your parents are
that was this matter it was a super
Harry Potter moment it was so Harry
Potter I was fine with it well it's
funny too because I play a Star Wars RPG
and in it we stream it live on on Twitch
on Friday nights though I think we're
moving to another day next year at 9
p.m. Pacific on hyper RPG let's switch
channel I work for I
it's called pencils and parsecs it's
real fun but we've been in we literally
when I saw last Jedi we had just had a
whole thing in a Sith temple where we
like went into this creepy mist and
started saying weird visions so I felt
very connected to that same with right
it's crazy because I feel like and we
can get into this little with the porn
thing Rian Johnson his ability to
predict like what the conversation yeah
he is really it's outrageous because the
pork scene that we're gonna get yes I
was convinced that that was just like
added the other day I don't disagree
with you on that but I found out that
that has been in the script at the
entire time who could predict I know
that eating pork would be the massive
conversation Rian Johnson damn he sure
did well I mean
I guess it sort of makes sense when you
look at okay we've mostly seen them in
marketing with Chewbacca who was a giant
Wookiee obviously consumes meat so let's
get to the port yes
these guys they're all boys because I'm
sure you experience this as well people
like really loved him at first and then
there was the port backlash yes where
everyone was like stop talking about
porks your sewin listen I feel like with
the pork we are seeing exactly what
we're seeing with the film last Jedi as
a whole that they're they're very
divisive very divisive little creatures
did the ports live up to your
expectations oh man I thought that the
use of the pores in the film was just
perfect perfect perfect about the
perfect amount they were cute they did
some funny things but they never impeded
the storytelling so I think this is in
the visual dictionary there's concept
art of the pour'd getting impaled by a
lightsaber I saw that someone tweeted
that the other day I think they tweeted
it at you also did my heart was very
broken so what the hell listen I am fine
with the Chewbacca grilling the porgy
scene because that makes sense is you
know wookies gotta eat man when you when
you saw that what was your because I I
legitimately was sitting two rows behind
ken knapsack who has been my pork
nemesis my arch nemesis and I this scene
pops up and I'm just like no no and I
scream it
my pork arch nemesis it's a little bit
Ken but it's more so the GM of our edge
of the Empire campaign Bert Jennings who
also hates porks he hates them and talks
about how they should be eaten we had
this whole thing where we tormented him
and made him or a pork costume one time
it was awesome he also recently murdered
the pork that our party had acquired
still dealing with that sadness but I
immediately thought of all the people
that
hated porks in that barbecuing scene and
I was like well you know what this is in
there for them this is their most of
their moment the rest of the happening
portrays mine are you happy but it's
funny because clearly Rian Johnson loves
the porks yes and the fact that it was
this scene of chewy had clearly killed
them and was and was grilling them but
then like there's this little sad family
reports just like like batting their sad
little die I need that gift forever it's
so sweet it was so cute and then chewy
stops he's like oh man I'm just like if
this plate just take a bite
yeah how many did you eat before we even
got there right and and and like we
didn't witness him murdering and de
feathering so oh my god there's a whole
process to get to the point that we saw
them on the barbecue spits so thank you
ryan johnson for not showing that i
think the pork haters would have enjoyed
it but I know that you like myself and
Ashe are a pork fan so we hate sparing
us the gory details another thing in the
in the visual dictionary is that they
have the the port on the on the spit
right right without the legs and it says
that it's because the legs are the
tastiest part to wookies so no like why
why why did you create these adorable
things to just specify how they would be
murdered and consumed I'm not cool with
that do you think that there will be
pours in Episode nine because there were
some stowaways on that I know I sure
hope so
I just because I I sort of am of the
opinion that episode nine there's gonna
be a big time jump that's that's sort of
my theory and I mean that's what's so
exciting about the ending of last Jedi
is who knows where it's gonna go it like
the possibilities are endless and that
is thrilling yeah because if you look at
the end of even Empire Strikes Back it
was so clear that you had to go right
back into exactly where we were right
force awakens JJ
Abrams set up all of these sort of
storylines that okay well we need to
continue those right but it's wrapped up
a lot of storylines and left you in a
place of who knows this movie for me was
like I think it's so fun to speculate
and do these videos yeah speculate about
what could happen but it's just like
throw them in the trash sure absolutely
but but speaking to the continuation of
ports I feel like because we did have
those stowaways on the Falcon what I
would like to see is a time jump and you
know porks playing a crucial part in the
resistance probably in a like a sort of
mechanic capacity where they assist with
you know the construction and repair of
weapons and maybe vehicles but yeah I
will
that's ports reaching their full
potential yeah maybe maybe like a few
force-sensitive yeah oh definitely
mm-hmm Broome kid just has a port
oh yeah it's like instead of a droid yes
we think that's really what we need is
we need Broome kid to be sort of like an
anime character who goes around with a
mascot all the time in his mascot is a
pork of course yeah who assists him with
some of his his force training I think
you this article was treated tweeted at
you the other day as well about how the
reason that the poor exist is because
there's so many puffins on the island
they're filming they needed to like
justify the amount of birds that were
there we have to make them all port yes
because when I first when I was first
watching it I got a little nervous
because it was like there were so many
pork noises and yes this is a lot of
pork noises yeah I don't want them and
then I watched it the second time when I
was like never mind it doesn't bother me
no no definitely not again it just kind
of adds to the environment I think it
was such a clever way for them to deal
with their actual filming condition yes
though I read that Rian Johnson was
gifted a pork like one of the yeah but
like full working poor puppets I would
like one I really want I don't know what
I need to do I know like who I will show
what every michelle diseases poor yeah I
totally agree in that and that I think
was another one of the things that I
really liked about the stuff with the
porks was so many of them were puppets
and they looked just that little tiny
bit janky just like the Yoda puppet like
just a little bit and it was so
Oh endearing and and just brought you
back to what I loved about the original
films as a kid I mean when I was little
my favorite movie in the entire world my
first favorite movie ever was the Dark
Crystal
so I'm like all in puppets all the time
and so you know to see the Yoda puppet
come back and then yeah the volp Tex
puppets were so unbelievable they were
cool like they were very cool it just I
don't know it was very charming and then
they were like they made that like
sparkly noise whenever they arose like
oh my god I love them they're so sexy
though here's the thing and I've said
this before but like the volt Texas are
I relate more to the pork like yeah I'm
I'm like kind of cute I guess
very annoying I feel like everyone's on
board with the bold text like man those
wolves are sick and the pork some people
are like I don't know about I feel about
these things do they really have a place
in Star Wars do I look at this and go
this belongs in Star Wars and and you
know I I feel that that's that's where I
fit into the answer is yes yes that's me
what is she doing yes well um I want to
thank you so much yeah bring the ball to
me then what guy just wants to nosedive
let's fix him and I'm so glad we got to
meet in here senator
yep surrounded by porks surrounded by
parts um so there are so many places
where everybody can find yourself yeah
that you less those absolutely so I so
ash and I also sort of have the collider
connections yes I do
primarily these days for Collider I'm
working on the movie trivia Schmo down
which is our movie trivia show that is
really a wrestling show with movie
trivia I am super energy I am the golden
mic I am the the postgame interview or
the the ultimate face
interviewer we have other people that
are sort of in the middle and more on
the heel side of things but I am a good
guy so then of course tomorrow which is
Friday the 22nd of December or whatever
you're watching this go back if it's
past the 22nd of December it's there on
collider and you can watch the Schmo
down spectacular - which is our big sort
of WrestleMania event to wrap up the
year there are a lot of twists and turns
and it's it was a good old time also I
I am part again of a Star Wars
role-playing game it's very thrilling to
get to explore the Star Wars galaxy in a
in a way that is very unique as a
character that I created I play the
captain of a small freighter I'm kind of
a narrow dual smuggler type and that
shows called pencils in parsecs that is
over on hyper RPG as I say I think we
are moving to Wednesday's next year but
as of right now we're on Fridays at 9
o'clock p.m. Pacific time it is a great
time though if you like
porks you might get your heart broken
because our GM hates them yeah and so
yeah I'm just I'm on the internet man
that's me I'm just a demo Fife doing
doing the thing doing the stuff talking
a lot about Star Wars right now because
this building has a lot to talk about in
it yeah we are here to talk to about
star yes the last Jedi he's like you
guys can find me at Ash cross and as
always talk about porks hash tag pork
nation pork nation thank you guys so
much for watching and see you next time